with presidential elections just
five months off opponents of nicaragua's
president daniel ortega
and his wife rosalio murillo the vice
president
are dropping like flies
in recent weeks two opposition parties
were dissolved
and two candidates put under house
arrest under a new electoral reform
measure that the u.n high commissioner
for human rights
says will impede fair and free elections
now cristiana chamorro the most
competitive opposition candidate
is being accused of money laundering and
other crimes that would make her
ineligible to run she is the daughter of
former president joletta chamorro
who beat ortega in elections back in
1990
this is not about attacking me it's
about attacking the right of nicaraguans
to a fair
free and transparent election they want
to eliminate all of us
to frighten us all so we won't
participate
leaving the general prosecutor's office
chamorro said her lawyers were also
being threatened
nicaragua's pro-government prosecutor
says that the violeta chamorro
foundation that she leads
and which receives donations from abroad
to support
independent journalism is being
investigated for money laundering
over the weekend the vice president
confirmed that the foundation's
accountant
and its finance manager had been
arrested and will remain
imprisoned for up to 90 days while
they're investigated
the government has not responded to al
jazeera's request for comment
but vice president murillo says
opposition leaders are guilty of
organized crime
but that's not all at least a dozen
journalists
including the afp correspondent have
been detained
questioned or charged with possible
complicity
maria lilly delgado correspondent of the
us-based spanish language network u
division
says her bank accounts have also been
frozen
i asked the prosecutor what crime was i
being investigated for
and he said he would withhold that
information how am i supposed to defend
myself
the office of the independent news
organization confidential
has also been raided and shut down its
director carlos fernando chamorro
is cristiano chamorro's brother
we journalists practice journalism not
treason they destroyed everything
took all our equipment and arrested our
cameraman they're trying to crush
any voice that challenges the
dictatorship in our case journalists who
hold power to account
president ortega who controls all of
nicaragua's institutions
and who has the support of cuba and
venezuela is running for a fourth
consecutive term
and just like in venezuela the
opposition
will soon have to decide whether to
compete at all
in elections that they say have already
been decided
to see a newman al jazeera